[Music]
we're back here we are mr dom billy
you've taken your shoes off again
another great sign of comfort between
friends i felt a certain heat in the
room yeah and i felt like my feet had to
breathe in electricity maybe oh you're
turning yourself on or up i'm turning
myself up and you i'm not taking my
shoes off because i'm i'm taking great
joy in these shoes today look at that
are they from the future and they're
great they are a little bit like moon
boots
like if i was doing a job say for
instance and i lived on the moon
and they said would your character wear
these i'd say yeah yeah he would yeah
they look they look cool have you seen
that fantastic duncan jones film moon
i have done this very sam rockwell
living on the moon but he doesn't wear
shoes like that no he doesn't he wears a
lot of uh
astronauty type stuff but what what a
wonderful film that is
who makes those shoes i actually don't
know because i got these shoes from
instagram so when i was scrolling
through my feed it will start to throw
up things that it thinks you might want
to buy and a lot of it for me is like
unique and strange flower pots because i
do a lot of gardening and i have a lot
of you know like strange indoor flower
pots right and
weird shoes because i do a lot of
searches for shoes this came up i was
like yeah okay i'll buy those i can't
remember the company chinese i think
wow they're amazing i like chinese i
like that song from money person i like
their tiny little trees
i think those are really incredible
shoes well done dumb you can loan them
whenever you want or is it borrow i
never know which one it is it would be
boral you can borrow them whenever they
want although i think are your your feet
a little smaller than mine i would think
so look at the size of your feet i'm a
10.
a tens oh yeah what are you a nine
that's not too bad well i thought you'd
be bigger than a ten no they look big
thank you
anyway what's going on yeah usual sort
of thing uh
i had a little i had a little vacation
for the first time holiday
huh as madonna said see when that song
came out when her first song came out i
said she'll be a one-hit wonder
she wasn't you normally bang on with
that stuff i got that one so wrong do
you remember there was a point she's
people probably listening to this
podcast now don't remember just how big
madonna got but there was a point where
she was the biggest kind of star in the
world wasn't she oh yeah massive and
also some other early stuff i love
borderline remember
[Music]
feels like i'm going to lose my
so that i think she lives in a like a
border town
like maybe in between one state and the
other like it's like a
washington dc washington dc which is in
between canada and in the united states
no no it's between two states here's my
hand ah right i've got california here
and i've got new york at my my finger
there yeah where is washington dc i'm
going to say the very bottom here like
now they're in there near the right here
yeah no it's way over here near my ring
finger yeah and it sits there and it's
not a state
it just sits
i don't know where it is
washington washington state this
washington state washington state is
over here just underneath my thumb right
washington dc is about as far away as
you can get and that's do you know what
the dc stands for district of columbia
what does that have to do with colombia
well the thing is it's not a state it
sits between here's my guess
pennsylvania
um
well john said no but i think i'm right
pennsylvania detroit michigan no that's
up here and that's the shape of a hand
on my hand in your hand wait
what does washington state
washington dc sits between two states
what are they john john errors
i know it's maryland and
maryland it's maryland which we call
maryland hey buddy you're from maryland
where all the cookies get made send us
over a pecan pie
that's why that's how you guys sound in
our ears that's brilliant tom yeah
thanks sounded like you were from
washington dc district of columbia i
don't know why does it have something to
do with columbus it's got something to
do with they don't allow it to be a
state because that's what the president
is but it's so confusing because it's
called washington state no that's a
different place oh buddy
really
you're from washington state or
washington dc buddy oh that's a [ __ ]
anyway back to madonna she is dating a
guy when borderline or that during this
song okay and the love is so strong
right that sometimes she has to get
across to the other state just to take a
breath for a second you keep on pushing
my love over the borderline to
washington dc washington which isn't
actually a state between maryland and
virginia but it wasn't supposed to be a
little trivia supposed to be in
philadelphia but they had to compromise
and put it between those two states
because that was basically the division
between the north and south oh and it's
not it's not a state you can confirm
that it's not a state they're trying to
make it a statement that's a big push
that they're trying to do thanks johnny
boy the tagline for virginia i know this
because my wonderful friend carrie comes
from there and i think this is lovely
virginia is for lovers
isn't that great so if you go to
virginia you're expected to
maybe have a little well maybe that's
where madonna was during borderline do
you have a favorite madonna song and a
favorite madonna period where you think
i'd like to kiss her on the face
uh um
i like holiday i like to like holiday
celebrate
yeah that's good
yeah and what about when is she the most
attractive to you well i thought she was
going to be a one-hit wonder well she's
not but i didn't 25 hit wonder yeah no
but i know i i was never really a huge
madonna fan i'm sorry oh okay all right
she just she didn't tickle your fancy no
she wasn't my thing at the same time
nina brought out 99 red balloons and i
said she's a stare
we'll be hearing about her
well into the millennium and she only
had one hit which she parlayed into two
hits by doing an english version
and a version
alpha deutsch
in german well my favorite madonna song
i'm a big fan of cherish
cherish his love how does that go again
cherished
cherished the diddly
so tired of guys and stuff and people
saying i'm not nice when i'm kind of
nice and i'm a lovely person yes i make
a lot of cash but i'm nice to my friends
cherish me i'm on the beach in black and
white and my hair's quite short so
something else in real high harmonies
cherish
that's perfect thank you that's a good
version of that song perfect version if
anybody out there could stick that to a
beat i would like to hear that in a kind
of like a uk garage style oh i like that
too yeah like a stormzy beat so i like
cherish the song but in terms of when is
madonna the most attractive
justify my love justify my look remember
that video naughty i can't remember the
song could you could you stop my memory
for you
justify my love and she's all like quite
marilyn monroe kind of heavy
curly blonde hair
you know dark
mascara she's falling out of hotel rooms
laughing what's she laughing about
she's laughing at what she got to the
night before
they ordered room service and they did
not give a hoot about how much it would
cost
yes and both of them will eat both who
cares we'll throw it on the floor well
it's probably on the record label
they're probably paying for it good
point you know what i mean no wonder
she's laughing very attractive at that
point anyway i don't know why we started
talking about madonna hey john
it's a little warm in here
there's any chance we could go down a
degree or two would you think though
yeah all right yeah yeah my top lip's
sweating oh is it wait a minute i've
just looked at your top lip
i've grown a moustache i can see that
here when did you do that well what i
did was i had a little bit of a beard
right and i thought okay here we go i'll
clip it down i thought well i'll leave
my mustache until last and then when i
left it i thought
actually
you've got like a little bit of a david
niven vibe going on keep it it's nice
though keep it the moon's a balloon
is it that's what david nevin one of his
books is called one of his
autobiographies was he also an author
wrote about his life i would suggest you
read it
really
here's here's the here's the david niven
story that stayed with me from that book
he just comes to hollywood
trying to be a star course he does he's
a beautiful man he's got a lovely voice
he's a very good actor
so he's been with the same agent for
years and years and years
gets to hollywood goes to a party one of
the big agents is there from one of the
big companies let's call it
c-a-a yeah right and the big artie
goffman artie goffman hey i'm marty
and he gets he gets introduced to our
goffman what what's happening fella with
your mustache and you look like james
bond we'll make you a big star i'm david
niven well what the [ __ ] you talking
like that you sound like an idiot you
gotta talk like me american come on go i
want you to be a star you are a star
buddy naming lights should i come and
see you on monday you want me to rep you
i'll take 25 hey i'll make it 10 for you
buddy
so then david nevin gets this offer from
the big agent
on a friday night at the party
he calls up his other agent on the
saturday i'm sorry
the english guy i'm going to have to
leave you oh darling why we've been
together for 15 years because i've just
met someone who says he's going to make
me a star oh
that's quite irregular but i have to go
okay
and it went like that
sunday he's all excited of course he is
so he just you know he shaves it not the
moustache of course no no
here gets his hair done
buys a new suit
monday morning first thing gets to ca
doesn't he see the agent what are we
calling him again marty goffman
i've got a i've got an appointment with
artie goffman
come on in right you can be the
secretary right
the secretary says
i'll give you the line okay yeah give me
a line i'm sorry he died yesterday in
the car accident oh
please give me the line dom
well i'm terribly sorry he died
yesterday in a car accident he exploded
what do you mean i'm going to be a star
no no he's dead but you can't find him
on the freeway near to five
he's in a couple of bags
you are marvelous and that story is
directly from the moon's a balloon wow
when david nevin had a moustache just
like yours dumb well now look i'm not
i'm not angling i'm not fishing here for
anything but i have recently given you i
think three books three books i gave you
jaws
the story of a shark i don't want to
read it no don't especially if you're in
the water a lot
the story of a shark i gave you
mr strange love which is a biography
about peter sellers one of your favorite
actors of all time uh yeah and then was
it doom patrol i gave you yes that's
true yeah novel doing patrol
fantastic
i'll tell you the one i'm going to read
first jaws
it is a really fun book but yeah i mean
i know that you have
a slightly irrational fear
that you might get eaten by a shark and
jaws won't help that but it is a it is a
brilliant read as your wife started
reading the biography on robbie williams
no she's reading another book just now
about a woman who hits her head and then
wakens up five years later
um
with no memory
no memory of the five years right things
has just happened bang
wow
okay good well i look forward to hearing
but i look forward to reading jaws i
enjoyed the movie it was very good but
it has given me an irrational fear of a
shark the great great film from a master
filmmaker and everyone talks about that
kind of
crash zoom dolly thing that goes on in
jaws which is great but for me and this
has become a conversation that you know
is a little bit passe with jaws
they couldn't they didn't have a
jaws fish
that spielberg thought was good enough
on camera he thought that the movie
would get ruined if you saw the fish
very often and because of the limitation
of hoping for a great fish and it wasn't
there he was like right we're gonna have
to work around it we'll just feature
a fin and an eye and stuff like that and
that is what makes it scary isn't it
it's the inclination of the fish the
great filmmakers how they have to change
while they're making the movie and they
accidentally make a better movie than
they were going to make right because
they're brilliant
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails
dom
voicemails let's do it buddy
hi billy and dom i love the podcast my
name is maddie and i'm from minneapolis
minnesota i noticed you guys tried your
hand in a minnesotan accent in the last
episode but it sounded a bit more new
york so i thought i'd help you out with
some phrases that'll make you sound like
a true minnesotan
so instead of saying bag you should say
vague
instead of saying excuse me you should
really say oh let me squeeze right past
you
and instead of saying yes or no
you can say oh no yeah or oh yeah no
oh yeah and these phrases will help you
seem right at home in minnesota
thanks so much i hope to see you guys
practicing and have a great rest of your
day let me squeeze right past you let me
squeeze right past you oh yeah no and
the oh yeah no and they say they don't
say minnesota they say minnesota
minnesota minnesota
thanks maddie thank you for the tips and
uh helping us out with my our american
accents uh
i think our american accent's to be fair
oh pretty fantastic yeah we pretty much
nailed you that tom
anyway
let me squeeze right past you let me
squeeze right past you buddy
move the keystone ah yeah no
no we all know we need to drink more
water but how we're going to do that
i'll tell you one thing that helps
liquid
iv one little packet of liquid iv poured
into 16 ounces of water will hydrate you
faster and more efficiently than just
water alone
it's a great thing to do first thing in
the morning when your body is craving
some hydration or maybe before a workout
or during a workout that's what i do
because i love the flavors
lemon lovely watermelon
they have all sorts though apple pie
strawberry guava
acai berry
and another great thing
it contains five essential vitamins it's
got more vitamin c than an orange more
potassium than a banana
and it's healthier than all those sugary
sports drinks no artificial flavors or
preservatives and less sugar than an
apple
so grab your liquid iv and bulk
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com and use
the code onion at checkout
that's 25
of anything you order when you get
better hydration today using promo code
onion
liquid iv.com
well it's almost time for those long
fall evenings or autumn as we would call
it it's time to get round the backyard
with your friends maybe have a few
drinks a barbecue and what do you need
when the evenings get cooler
a fire pit from solo stove
they are really fantastic they come in
different sizes
you can move them around they're not
stuck in one place a really fantastic
fire pit smokeless from solo stove i've
got one and i love it i use it every
week
made with premium grade 304 stainless
steel and a patented
360 degree air flow system that
maximizes efficiency while minimizing
smoke
get the perfect fire pit for those fall
nights and make your backyard a
destination with a spectacular fire pit
from solo stove
shop the fall event now and get an extra
ten dollars off when you use promo code
onion at checkout
they're so confident you'll love it they
offer a lifetime warranty and a 30-day
free return policy
just go to solostove.com
and remember you get ten dollars off
when you use promo code
onion
hey dom and billy this is luke from
kansas city i had two questions for you
guys if you had to choose tea or coffee
which one would you prefer
and also if you had to choose your hand
to be made out of butter or for your
tears to be liquid butter which one
would you rather
i love your guys show you guys have so
much fun and i have so much fun
listening to you guys
thank you
he's from kansas city oh kansas city
now why did he say kansas city is there
another kansas that's not a city no i
don't know i mean there's there's well
there's if we open up a little bit of
canada worms here aren't we because
there's
arkansas which looks like our kansas
which we
like a lot of people growing up in
britain call our kansas but it's not
arkansas
then there's kansas but we're not in
kansas anymore are we but we're never
we're in kansas city
no he's where he's from kansas city no
is that different from what
hold on john is kansas city different
from if i said i'm from kansas
yeah so it's kind of interesting okay uh
casters did a uh podcast opportunist on
uh it takes place in kansas city i
learned that kansas city is split as a
city in two states it's one and a half
is in kansas
and the other house is in missouri so
kansas city is in missouri half of it
i know it's a half but it's split
between those two states
one missouri is there a river i'll look
i'll see if there's a river a river runs
through it normally a river runs through
a major city anyway the questions yeah i
know how you're gonna answer tea or
coffee
well at the moment um i would have to go
coffee you're addicted i love coffee
you'd love it i absolutely but i love
tea you know
i like tea but i drink tea
what we call builders tea don't we yeah
i have a pg tips or a typhoo with some
milk in it and i and i enjoy that yeah
maybe a biscuit yeah i'm not really
doing it as a health i'm not having a
ginger and ginseng and you know green
tea and all that kind of stuff i'm just
having a nice cup of tea yeah no i hear
you
um
i like a cup of tea thick two the thing
with me
i started drinking coffee during this
whole coved lockdown thing
and unfortunately for me to chase the
feeling
i had to start drinking more and more
coffee my body very quickly built up a
resistance oh yeah to the magic so i
started one cup of coffee lovely lovely
little nice eventually became like four
or five cups of coffee i just thought i
don't want to do that so i'm not
drinking coffee anymore i do drink the
builder's tea thing that you talked
about pg tips yorkshire but i do like
the kind of medicinal tea so of an
evening maybe a chamomile tea just to
calm it right down now what did t.s
eliot say about i
had he count my life through coffee
spoons oh i don't know i don't know oh
he says something and i think i do that
i think every day is full of coffee and
uh you know i have my morning coffee and
then in the afternoon i think well have
a little coffee a little pick me up and
what kind will i have we're having a
double espresso with a touch of sugar or
will i just have a nice black coffee or
yeah of like you had told me during
during covid that you had said you know
you'll get into the ritual and you'll
enjoy the rich i love the ritual of
grinding up the coffee beans and then
put it in the little italian thing and
the noise
i love all that yeah but i just i
started chasing the dragon and i don't
want it i don't want to chase something
isn't ts eliot attributed with
in some way
writing cats because didn't he write a
bunch of poems about cats he did came
cats
and and you
became obsessed with the movie cats
and you might remember i sent you the
book of poetry from t.s eliot
cats yeah i don't know why he did it i
suppose for some kids in his family or
something i think he kept cats and he
started to be charmed by their
idiosyncratic ways so he wrote some
poems about them which then
very bizarrely i think andrew lloyd
webber was looking around for a musical
and he thought
t.s eliot's books poems about cats i'll
turn that into almost any musical you
can look at and go that sounds like a
terrible idea but it always works not
always but a lot of the time i mean the
film cats
didn't work so badly that it became like
a curiosity and i absolutely was
obsessed and continued to be obsessed
with it there is that one amazing song
in cat's memories
brilliant go under memory
[Music]
oh very poetic you're a music man
what's that thing that i'm doing there
that i'm not doing on purpose
midnight what's that vibrato now why do
people do that to sustain a note well
it's just
it's harder to hold i know
bang on mo
you stick a bit of vibrato on it
it's a bit easier to hold the note isn't
it okay and a lot of people say that's
where you get that sort of broadway
sound is there a lot of a brown lover i
do like it yeah it's it's a lovely thing
the person who does the most amazing
vibrato
if i'm thinking about it is that song
from
romeo and juliet you know where they
meet for the first time near the fish
tank and that lady sings that that song
kiss me yeah kissing me kissing you kiss
me
is that that excuse me under the name
we were having a romantic moment and
you've ruined it
no it's um
oh now i'm kind of oh it's a little road
can stay
1000
but watching stars
something like that and he's confused
because he sees this beautiful girl but
then he goes oh fish yeah she's a he's a
look at that guppy there yeah well she's
not oh hang on cnn
oh there she is again
there's a salmon
oh yeah so vibrato thanks for that bills
not at all
second half of that question that guy
sent in
would you rather have a buttery hand a
buttery hand or tears
of melted butter
i'd rather i'd rather cry tears because
i wouldn't like if you used your buttery
hand
like say i did a whole loaf of toast
would then
then i have no hand yeah you damage your
hand permanently or is it continually
seeping
butter well that that would be good if
it kind of re-re-re
but as long as i was under like i was
under my power yeah i'd hate to say
hello mr president
done and then for the rest of your life
just a buttery stump and he's like
you're never welcome in washington i
went iris then
washington dc again
yeah i'd like to cry
buttery tears
because then when you've made your toast
put on that moment in romeo and juliet
i think we're slightly off
and then you could cry into your toast
and all you need then is a little bit of
marmite done
would you always be sad when yet toast
then
sometimes a good cries good though makes
you feel better i like a good cry if i
want a good cry my go-to film for that
is e.t well is it really
more than more than um uh fried green
tomatoes never seen fried green tomatoes
you should watch it the whistle stop
cafe it's very good was that your go-to
cry film uh i've never cried though
you don't cry do you i'm a hard hard man
is there is there a sad film that you
that you think is your favorite sad film
scottish man
never shows emotion
i can't think i'll have a think about
that does gregory's girl not make you a
little emotional that makes me laugh
it's brilliant
so should we go into this uh question do
you want to read out this question here
bills or do you want me to i'll do it
it's from melissa
stanford
connecticut mr b there's a c in there
that should that c be there connect
connect i
cut connect this is how you can connect
to that break it down i cut right let's
dominate on my hand
can where would you find connected uh
you exactly where your wedding ring is
right there
i have no idea dom okay thanks i wanted
to thank you so much for the friendship
onion podcast it's really helped me
laugh and i needed that especially this
week the other day
uh i had to put our 19 year old cat down
oh wow 19. it was honestly one of the
hardest things i've ever had to do flynn
was a sweet friend to the whole family
and the house feels really empty without
him have you ever lost a pet and how did
you feel comforted after the passing dom
i know you have many exotic animals how
do you handle their deaths not trying to
bring the podcast down but i think
talking about these wonderful animals
creatures that we share so much of our
lives with helps in the healing process
[Music]
well sorry to hear that melissa it's
always sad when you when you lose a a
pet especially 19 years but yeah sounds
like he he was a wonderful friend to the
family that's a real shame i've got um
my friend bj bill johnson who you know
he just lost his dog and he gets super
um
close to his dogs you know as as we all
do it's awful and
you just wish that these dogs and cats
that we share our lives with would just
live the same
length it's a cruel trick
it is a cruel trick isn't it that one of
the closest relationships that you have
with another animal
they tend to live
15 years maximum most of them aren't
they
i was listening to the divine comedy the
other day and i was listening to one of
our songs and never noticed it before
but one of the lyrics was
you know at the end of your life the
only thing you'll regret
is all the dogs and cats that you've
that you've
you know didn't get to spend all your
life with but you get to see them
when you die
i subscribe to the idea that in a lot of
ways
something only excuse me something only
does when you forget about it
so as long as you're keeping that memory
alive and you talk about them in a
glowing way and they stay in your mind
and in your thoughts even though
physically they're not there
you can still think about them and
it's such a wonderful part of our lives
aren't there pets
it's really sad i'm sorry to hear that
melissa sorry to that melissa lots of
love to you yeah i hope you start to
feel better and thanks a lot for your
question sorry if there's anyone out
there that's also lost a pet recently
miro
miro is a collaborative whiteboarding
online platform it's created to help you
visualize and and discuss and
share all your work it's just like the
whiteboard you'd have in your office
where everyone can draw on it and write
things and put up sticky notes except
it's online
and all your colleagues or friends can
all meet up there and work or play
or whatever is in between
you can write on it you can draw on it
put up videos sticky notes diagrams
audio whatever you need to help
conceptualize your idea
it's a fantastic product and it's really
fun to use
it's great just now as well when people
are finding it difficult to collaborate
outside the normal office
it works a treat
miro is creating a revolution in how we
create and collaborate so join over 20
million users today
you can sign up and use miro today for
free
go to miro that's
miro dot com slash onion to start your
free account sign up today and take
advantage of three free white boards
with this exclusive offer go to miro
m-i-r-o dot com slash onion and start
using miro today
there's no reason to delay
are you finding it hard to think of what
to make for dinner every night
lunches
well i tell you who can help
green chef
green chef takes care of meal planning
grocery shopping and even some of the
food prep which leaves you more time to
do what you want to do
but on top of that
the recipes are really interesting
that's what i like
so i end up eating things i wouldn't
normally eat maybe some vegetables i
don't normally buy and i find it in
there and i use their recipes and it's
delicious
as well as that green chef is the most
sustainable meal kit so you can feel
great about what you're eating and how
it got to your table
it's actually the only meal kit
that's both plastic
and carbon offset
they are the number one meal kit for
eating well
so go to greenchef.com
onion100 and use the code
onion100 to get a hundred dollars off
including
free shipping
that's a hundred dollars off and free
shipping just go to green chef dot com
slash onion 100 and use code
onion 100.
here's another question from crow
wow
in latvia latvia
if my head was the world
where
oh depends where how it's spinning well
my eye my left eye
is um
the united kingdom
and my ear
is the very east coast of russia
where do you find latvia i'm gonna say
somewhere
close to the back of your hairline ish
up here no like here or here way down
there yeah not bad not bad so i guess
yeah it's a bad one anyway crow says i'm
a really big fan of lord rings i spent a
lot of time watching the scenes clips
from the movies too
because of this i want to be an actress
myself i have a few questions and here
they are what goes through your mind
while filming a scene in a movie or a tv
show
and then when you watch a movie do you
wonder what the actor is thinking
okay
well what goes through my mind when i'm
filming a scene is usually
what's going on in the scene
i'll try as hard as i can to like stay
in the moment so let's say
the character that i play has not seen
his
family
for years and he's seen them again
that's what i'm thinking while i'm in
the scene this is these are people who i
miss these are people who i love this is
an amazing moment for me to be here
and then when you watch a movie do you
wonder what the actor's thinking
not often i usually just think
if they're a good actor
i believe
yeah that they are in the scene having
the moment in fact
if i ever struggle with an actor's
performance it's when i'm
probably seeing the workings the cogs
yeah going a little bit i agree it's my
my favorite style of acting is is when
you don't see any of that when they're
not telling you
so yeah when i'm filming and and the
ideal
is uh when you're just living in the
scene and reacting and another level to
that in in film acting
when there is um
different takes and things i i enjoy the
technicality as well of
um
continuity and and giving editors a good
cut place i like i like doing things
where i know
like maybe i'll
cough at the same time so they've got a
nice cut there
and once i get into us i quite like
the sort of teamwork of thinking oh in
the edit this would be fun if i did i
picked that up and when i put it down on
that line i know they've got a good cut
to something else i enjoy that as well
collaboration the collaboration of the
whole thing um all right well thank you
crow what a fantastic name and then here
is lisey in fountain hills arizona vince
arizona fantastic place very hot very
hot it's a desert dog it is a desert
the year return the king cleaned up at
the academy awards is my favorite oscar
telecast honorable mentions go to the
year joel and ethan cohen won best
director for no country of all for old
men fantastic film
i'm curious if you guys are up on your
history what are your favorite academy
award wins and just in case y'all have
no idea what to say to that one do you
have any anecdotes about being at the
oscars ceremonies
i think um you you're probably more up
on the oscars and the history fan of the
oscars yeah you'll love it
i've watched it
like religiously even when i was uh
a youngster probably from the age of 13
or 14 i would stay up late and watched
it loved it um favorite years daniel day
lewis winning for my left foot was an
amazing moment because he was kind of he
just kind of arrived it seemed out of
nowhere although he had done films
before and you know became this massive
star
anthony hopkins winning for
sounds for the lambs was amazing right
and i also really like um
halle berry's uh
kind of reaction to her winning in oscar
which is one of complete kind of
overwhelmed joy i love seeing things
like that i love that yeah my my uh i
don't have much uh memories of watching
it even though i watch it every year but
when i was at the oscars that year for
return of the king my favorite memory is
i went out for a pee
and you're allowed to go for a pee
when uh the adverts are on
uh so you get the length of an advert to
go for a pee and they have people
dressed up
in evening attire right so if you go for
a pee sit in your seat seat fillers so
that it never looks like there's an
empty seat
and i took too long having a pee and
they closed the doors
so for one whole section i missed it and
i was outside just standing in line with
everyone else who'd missed the pee break
and i can't actually remember who was
there but i remember standing there and
thinking this is the weirdest most
surreal because there's people like you
know salma hayek and her dress and
you know prince and and i'm standing in
line to get back into this building with
these people i just thought this is
you know because it just shows everybody
human and needs a pee yeah but
here we are all waiting to get back in
and the guy who they brought in to
replace you to sit down
he and i are best mates that's dave
yeah
we actually own a couple of businesses
together and he's a lovely lad i was
best man at his wedding he's a great so
thank you for going for a pee
and
taking too much time washing your hands
that could have been me he's great he's
really close with elijah he's great
friends with sean
good lad dave hey dave if you're
listening
anyway i think that's it for the
question i think
we've got a couple of reviews here have
we should we read together should we
read one or two one
from eggnog pirate you do that one big
little pirate what a fantastic name says
i'm only two episodes in but it doesn't
feel like a podcast it feels like two
mates talking about their memories both
in relation to the lord of the rings and
life in general splendid job gents
gob gents nah i think that's probably
john yes says
that does say splendid gob but i'm going
to say that john probably meant job yeah
jobby i mean we don't tend to think too
much about the podcast because we've
always wanted it to be
kind of loosey-goosey that was
intentional but one of the things that
we set out to do
is let's have it feel
casual and fun and we're just having a
lovely chat and let's have the listeners
involved so you guys have questions
we're going to have another quiz i think
pretty soon more guests you know if you
have any ideas if you have questions for
us you want to be in the quiz you have
uh what's that thing called again well
they say something and you try and work
out what it is
you forgot the word riddle wow that's
that's crazy yeah i forgot the name for
pyramid once oh really does that happen
worse actually isn't it anyways we like
the interaction don't we we like we like
the kind of internet you guys are
creating the show with this type thing
and we didn't know today that we were
going to talk about cats or vibrato it
just happened didn't it yeah it does
because of what you guys say so send in
your emails to uh the friendship onion
at cassmedia.com
cast with a k or speak pipe forward
slash dot com i've ruined it no that was
good
dot com forward slash the friendship on
you yeah put a forward slash in there
and if you do review the show what you
should do you've got to like review
subscribe and then you have to take a
screenshot of the review and tag us at
the friendship onion and then we'll
feature you on the show
billy and dom eat the world
lovely stuff uh i think we're going to
do
billion dollar meets the world right now
and just so you know bills for the first
time ever
this is a surprise because john brought
something in that was recommended by a
listener and he said do you want to know
and we said no don't tell us
we don't know we have no idea why he
comes john we're going to eat his hand
it seems oh no oh oh
is that dragon fruit dragon fruit look
at that the juice that comes from it
makes you think of beetroot it is a
little beetrooty wow so i'm going to put
mine down for a second because i feel
like that's very stainy colored
now a dragon dragon fruit let me read
some of this stuff to you this was this
is recommended to us from harris
in eugene oregon
and dragon fruit it says here is a fruit
of many names known as bataya or pataya
patahaya depending on the genus as well
as strawberry pear and even night
blooming serious but in thailand it is
called tang loi
pitahaya is hailing from israel good
luck with this one and in hawaii it has
another name off you go
panini
very very good there remember we tried
to learn a little bit of tai because one
of the scale doubles on lauder ring fun
was a lovely lovely lady girl
called fawn who who doubled for pippin
most of the time i would think
remember her actual full name
chan santo prappahorn
and she was so lovely and she was
such a lovely person and we go to our
apartment and have little parties and
stuff
and she tried to teach us some tie so we
could say good morning and thank you
yeah and i asked her to tell me how to
say
you look lovely yeah you know and she
told us and she said but my
pronunciation made it sound like i was
saying i want to fight you oh yeah you
don't so you don't want those things to
sound like each other yeah and she used
to say to us quite a lot
what that mean you're crazy you're crazy
crazy and she taught us obviously like
which is like good morning and that's
the the it's tones and thai that we
don't have isn't it and they have a lot
of feminine and masculine so like we you
and i for thank you would say cop kung
cap but if it's a woman
and then do you remember what very tasty
was because i
memorized that because you say it all
the time in thailand because they take
their food very seriously
very tasty was arroyo
aroma
and they love it if you say their food
is tasty they love it anyway let's
continue this is called tang loi in
thailand yeah and also says in the
united states dragon fruit continues to
gain popularity which is spurring
expansion in commercial production a
number of dragon fruit species are grown
around the world from asia middle east
central and south america vietnam is
asia's top producer primarily growing
fruit with bright pink skin and white
flesh that's the stuff that i've had
before but this is red
flesh other asian countries cultivating
the fruit include malaysia i've been
there the philippines i've been there
sri lanka i've been there thailand
taiwan i've not been there thailand
we've been there we went to thailand of
course we did no dom i mean john
john where is this one from do you know
ralph's ralph's it's from ralph's ralph
lovely ralph thank you round it's got a
red red red red ring
ready done well
yes i'm having a huge chunk i hope it's
like
the smell is not hold on it doesn't
smell particularly inviting no
it smells of earth
says hey
dragon fruit is often consumed flesh
much like a kiwi and the plant small
flower is edible when cooked rich in
protein fiber and iron antioxidants is a
popular fruit in fruit bars jellies
fruits yogurts smoothies red varieties
can also be used as a natural dye or
colorant
should we give it a go i wonder what's
the difference between a dye or a
colorant yeah let's find that out if
anyone knows the difference i'm going to
give it ready yeah i'm having the whole
thing me too are you doing it that's it
there's a little pomegranate taste to
that
are you getting that yeah i'm getting
that actually
i love fruit
i've not met a fruit that i don't like
yet
even durian which is quite a
controversial fruit in southeast asia i
love it
while dragon fruit is a cousin of the
prickle of the cactus pear
which grows in my garden the true fruits
exhibit key differences first pattaya
seeds which we're eating now are edible
much like the kiwi fruit second the
fruit does not typically have spines
instead possesses various colored
protective shoots that surround the
baseball sized fruit baseball size it's
more softball size than baseball it's
huge it's massive unless we've still got
tiny tiny little hobbit hands um
name a fruit where the seeds are on the
outside strawberry perfect um i've
absolutely nailed it you got that one
um
how do you define a fruit
it grows on a tree
no
because pineapples are fruit isn't it
does that not grow in a tree it grows in
the ground pineapple well it's a
vegetable then
now
you sure yeah right go on then fruit
seeds
the seeds and nuts got seeds or tomatoes
it's a fruit would you say tomato or
tomato i'd say tomato but do scottish
people say tomato nobody's good for
microwave oh gosh do you have a favorite
way of eating a tomato because some
versions of tomatoes i don't like i
don't like the snotty gooey stuff
inside a tomato but in a greek salad
love it hmm what about you
i like it just yeah just with some salt
on it
oh really that's quite kind of british
that isn't it just like
you you slice tomatoes and then you
sprinkle some salt underneath it i was
helping a friend get ready for dinner
once and i think you were there and
there was tomatoes and i was putting
salt on and now a woman came in an
elderly woman came in and said how do
you know that they want salt on their
tomatoes i said i don't even know if
they want tomatoes
hey it's tasty
what do you think of it dom
oh [ __ ] crackle
um
well not as intense as i would have
hoped
little pomegranate juice i think you
were onto something with the beetroot
taste is there a slight beetrooty vibe
yeah almost a vegetable yeah there's a
there's an earthy earthy
lovely
you've nailed it there it's a semi-spiny
plant and it can have long fleshy
triangular stem segments that should be
pruned regularly commercial orchards
need their
trellising system to support the plant's
vertical growth and aerial roots trellis
something to grow up it's amazing how
plants do that i had a house once
and the roots grew
in the gaps between the
bricks and then they went into the you
know into the house how does it do that
plants are amazing i mean nature is
amazing and the word awesome
is thrown around willy nilly sure as bye
people but if you really want to see
something extremely awesome
nature
the life of animals and plants and
mosses and trees and stuff incredible
and planets i think planets are planets
galaxies sour sweets sour sweets so sour
sweets are so nippy on your tongue
as a night bloomer the plant has a
yellowish green fragrant flower that
opens early in the evening and will wilt
by daylight due to light and temperature
i'm going to guess that that is a
fruit that is pollinated by bats then
since the plant opens at night i have
some cactus that only flowers at night
and i have a bunch of bats that come and
drink its nectar and pollinate it no i
would like to know about this plant and
you might not have it here dom so you
keep scanning and keep reading scrolling
i'd like to know if you were the type of
person
who would eat
you know to be healthy
and maybe to fix an ailment what would
you eat this dragon fruit for yeah
that's a good point what what is it good
for i mean outside of just the tastiness
of it and you can imagine it being
really refreshing in a country you know
kind of hydration high vibrational water
but um also i would say the seeds which
you can't
kind of eat all of the seeds before you
swallow them swallow them i'm wondering
if the seeds are good for your gut
because they dragged some of the dude
tried to strew some of the old stuff
some of the stuff
well dom
i finished mine
wait did you eat that big did you get a
big bit with it as well yeah how did you
eat that what big bat i got that no you
got the big [ __ ] oh okay but uh so i i
i must have liked it but it's not as i
feel as if i might have got another one
of these and i'll try it again it's
maybe the first time i've tried that
yeah dragon fruit and
i would try it again but i feel as if
there's probably a more intense one
do you mean sour
i don't know just a more like i get that
earthy taste and i get the pomegranate
thing you're talking about but i feel as
if
it should be more intense
okay
i mean do you have a favorite fruit
i love a melon of course you do you're
only human i love melee is it anywhere
near the chart of a melon for you or are
you putting it in the kind of average
fruit that's what i'm thinking you know
if i got a melon that was just a little
too old or something and it lost that
strong melon i feel as if there might be
a stronger dragon fruit taste that i'm
lacking here and i'm not blaming jon for
this or don't blame me or ralph's or the
dragon fruit or the dragon i'm not
putting the blame on anyone no no i'm
just saying there might be a more
intense experience for me out there
somewhere never play the blame game
never but what i would say is a strength
and a weakness of fruit your greatest
strength is your greatest weakness is
there is a lack of consistency with
fruit so you might get an apple from a
tree
and you eat it and you think that is the
greatest apple that i've had you take
another apple from the same tree right
next to it and you think absolute is
piss because there's no consistency with
fruit so it's a bit of a gamble that
might have been
a slightly average dragon fruit yeah but
still quite tasty very tasty and see
when you were doing the whole apple tree
thing there i could see you as adam in
in
a sort of
a remake of the biblical story
from the old testament
i saw you
as adam
and madonna as eve cherish
yeah
she'd need a heck of a large snake to
cover up some of her
bits
you know what i'm talking about
and it's all uh it's only an apple i
mean they've got everything yeah
don't touch that apple no i'm fine you
got everything you live in paradise you
don't want for anything there's nothing
here that you need to worry about just
don't don't can i have the banana yeah
yeah tangerine yeah no problem dragging
for it sure
don't eat the apple no no we won't eat
the apple
you had it no i didn't have it eve had
it what was it i thought it was i just
saw you picking it what was it you says
oh i'll have that apple not fully versed
on
all of the stories in in the bible
basically one of them
but you would be wonderful is what i'm
saying they were both told
have whatever you want but don't have
that fruit and one of them
tried the fruit and then everything
from that point should we give it some
scores go on tom first of all
flavor flavor
well as i say i enjoyed the flavor i
like the pomegranate thing you were
talking about i like the earthiness i
don't think i think there's a better
dragon fruit out there of course there
is
oh dragon fruit 8.2
i'm going to give it for flavor i agree
with you i think there's probably a
slightly kind of more fried in the sun
concentrated flavor i'm gonna give it an
eight
not bad
aesthetics could you hold up your big
thing i beg your pardon could you ah
look how beautiful wonderful i mean you
can't even imagine that nature could
create something that color here is and
let me see the inside of it here's the
front right
and here is the inside look at what some
people might call the interior i mean
it's a beautiful it's red deep deep deep
dress scarlet is that what that means
it's like a ox blood yeah oxblood red
stunning sky at night
i mean in terms of appearance
i'm giving that a 9.7 of course you are
dumb and i'm giving a 9.8 oh you're
always trumping me
and then in terms of usefulness i don't
know because i've not had it in a bunch
of different ways that might be the only
way that i've had it although i'm
guessing i did have it in a fruit salad
once in
southeast asia but the flesh was white
and the seeds were black much like a
licorice all sort
so is the black and white one cheaper
than the color
like a tv license
possibly we can find out if we have any
southeast asian friends out there that
know the answer to that question
uh quite possibly but it was very tasty
i'm sure
you put it in a smoothie oh i'm sure
there's dragon fruit ice cream i'm sure
it's not yeah
yeah do you know what i mean no this is
dragon fruit sweeties what's the thing
you have is the root
maybe the root of an orchid maybe and
you have it
and it's a something fruit but it's not
dragon fruit but we remember we used to
go to a vegan place down on main street
and i would always get it in a curry
lotus root is that does it have a little
yeah
lotus roots i'm getting confused with
that and dragging through it yeah it's
different totally different well dragon
fruit looks like it's true it's just a
rhyming thing yeah so if i were to say
to you trumpet toot would you get
confused with that as well yeah
your favorite suit
yeah tomato soup
your mind you get we're all getting old
billy that's what's going on but it's
delicious dog and how useful is it i
mean i'd say various i'd say very useful
i'm gonna give it a nine
i'm gonna give her an 8.7 oh thank you
for under trumping me this time
fantastic stuff please send in your
suggestions for uh billion dom eat the
world to us friendship onion ah
casmania casmania.com that's class with
a key
and if you have a link that you can put
on there so it's easier for us to find
it please stick it on there but it's
fantastic we're eating the world we are
eating the world
[Music]
thank you now bills we have been sent
here a wonderful song
by daniel s from medellin in colombia oh
and this is a song by hansi kirsch a
german singer songwriter
and former bass guitarist best known as
a member of the power metal blind band
blind guardian that's a super one of the
founders of the band he has been its
lead vocalist kirsch the lead vocalist
kirsch's lyrics revolve around various
themes prevalent in the power metal
genre including medieval fantasy jrr
tolkien religious mythological tales and
legend stories both his own and from the
literary world and this is a song called
lord of the rings by blind guardian
wonderbar stick it in our ears jono
[Music]
now i'm picturing there
a kind of beardy weirdy guy right
in the corner of a tavern where
sweden
lovely swedish countryside
the tavern is heated
by simply logs in a fire
the only thing on the menu
is uh
little pieces of a dead animal a white
sausage maybe a white sausage they serve
ale there's no wine there's no cocktails
there's not that type of place ale ale
white sausage white sausage homemade
bread
there could be a cup a family of mice
running around in the corner everyone's
okay with it and a large dog breed
unknown yes yes and our friend
hansi kirsch is sat in the corner with a
12-string guitar tuning it with his back
to the to the crowd and then he turns
and says listen to this you bastards and
he goes
here's the song of many rings
[ __ ] oh did you write that it was not
sir influenced by professor tolkien
but this is mine stool
he says about his chair that he is
sitting upon yeah
and they go but is it funky a hansi at
any point does it become funky and he
says no knights is not funk it's more of
a tale a yarn nine nine nine riders nine
men doomed to die
no so
it's lovely and we love songs that
feature uh lord of the rings
oh zeppelin
you know yes i think maybe had something
yesterday i think so
did uh zeppelin do a song about the nas
school yes they mentioned the nas girl
for sure they mentioned oh all sorts
they love lauder rings
uh do that beyonce did a song about lord
of the rings which was amazing
if you liked it
written from uh gollum's point of view
yeah wonderful yeah have you seen the
little babies dancing to uh
oh no no oh billy you're not often in a
bad mood but let me tell you if you're
ever in a bad mood google search baby
dances to beyonce and you'll see little
kids in like nappies just not being able
to sit still because beyonce is
brilliant
lovely song daniel s meddling sent that
from columbia was blind guardian funky
dumb medalline midday in midair you
should know that if you've ever watched
i watched a couple all right
is it funky on a scale of brahms to
prince
i'm gonna say
mozart
it's good but it's not funky right i'll
say
black sabbath
it's got drums
and it's not funky tiny like a the hint
of funk but it's just but not really
could be funky
we like that he's taken the world j j r
r tolkien and he's made it his own
lovely stuff thank you daniel s for
sending in that song and please send in
your suggestions for songs if you want
us to find out if it's funky or not and
of course it will feature on our spotify
playlist the french onion which is
getting
larger and larger as each week passes
like the universe and my belly full of
dragon fruit guys we've run out of time
that's it but please rate and review and
subscribe to the friendship opponent and
if you rate and review us we may grab
that review and put it up on our social
media yeah don't forget to take a
screenshot and stick it on at the
friendship onion and we'll see you next
week don't forget to write
at the friendship on not at no different
he does this he does it hang on his
brain's exploded he's he's
how sad
you can do it
the friendship onion at
cashmedia.com he's nailed it guys we'll
see you next week see you next week
toodles
[Music]